a live comedy showcase livestream with
comedians in their quarantine states and
bringing laughter - everybody is it's
being described to raise as much money
to help comedians who are and others who
are battling kovat 19 comedy gives back
calm is how you can learn more and how
you can stream it live on Twitch Twitter
the Laugh lounge app and Comedy
Central's YouTube channel starting at
7:00 Eastern tomorrow at 4:00 Pacific on
the 4th of April and one of the
comedians one of our friends here from
the Rich Eisen show joining us bill burr
how are you bill Rhett's how you doing
I'm hanging in there everybody in your
family everybody good healthy best we
can tell everybody symptom free and I
don't think I've been to the end of my
driveway in three days doing what
they're saying I went out to get the
trash cans and bring them back in but
I'm just doing what they're telling me
to do for once but it's gonna be the
contrarian comedian I downplayed the
whole thing yeah they're overreacting
but I did that for a little bit I was
just like alright they shut down the
city I'm gonna you know I'm going this
looks like a snake Plissken movie here
I'm just gonna stay until they tell me
it's okay I mean I go out for drives
everything every two three days the wife
and kid we go a little stir-crazy so
we'll go out for like a drive windows up
and that type of thing right no I know I
know and it's it's obviously something
very serious but you're in a position
just like in a way that we are where a
lot of people are looking for a break
they're looking for a break they're
looking for some sort of escape while
understanding that the world is you know
crumbling in many ways that they want to
feel normal they want to have a laugh
and and that's where this comes in house
it's gonna work tomorrow you got like a
time like it's just basically like a
live stream comedy club where you got a
set time for you to go up and do your
set somewhere I mean how's that gonna
work tomorrow no it's more like what we
did was I do a podcast with Bert
Kreischer star of hey big boy it's on
Netflix streaming now look at that
little team came out that guys I owe you
the best so I do I do a podcast with him
called the bill bird podcast and Thom
popper is going to be the host and he's
going to just throw it to us and we're
going to do just 12 minutes we're both
such a couple of dopes that just are
talking evidently everybody just laughs
at us in it I don't know makes people
laugh and stuff but uh bill I'm you know
it's a little more deeper than that but
I've been doing this thing with Bert for
like the last year and I'm just having
such a great time doing a podcast with
him so hopefully people will tune in but
like you know Conan's doing something
Jimmy Fallon Adam Sandler we won't be
singing imagine so don't worry I didn't
see you in gals Instagram bill I didn't
see you in that one I just feel like I
mean I don't know who talked them into
that like how it's just gonna work I'm
you know it's just one of those things I
feel bad cuz you know their heart was in
the right place right and you go out
there and you got to sing acapella in
like your yard and you don't know what
key anybody else is really singing in
you sort of know the key alright the
whole thing it's just it's just god
bless you could see it read shake this
is what song would you have chosen bill
you got a good song that you would
[Music]
what's next to the moon
ac/dc I don't like deep cut I'd go a
deep cut so they wouldn't notice that I
was singing bad they'd be like I know
this song what is this maybe so focused
on that maybe I'd get away with it but
if you spend a huge hit like imagine
like this is John Lennon imagine the
hell I guess that's what I like when
they go imagine there's no heaven and
everybody got offended by that why would
you say that during this time it's like
the songs been out for like 50 years
they've been saying it forever
alright now you get offended in 2020
bill burr here on the Rich Eisen show
alright man
Brady's at Buccaneer how you handle that
one dude it took me two weeks and then
this wave of sadness hit me that I
finally realized you know
dealing with is are they ever gonna have
pork chops again you know and there was
a whole stupid run of the at the grocery
stores you know like chickens had
coronavirus when they didn't I took me
two weeks to first to finally hit me and
then this real like sadness the sadness
of when a great player retires or moves
on to another team I'll even say it's a
Red Sox fan it took me two seasons of
watching the Yankees to stop looking for
Derek Jeter at shortstop and just
feeling the void of that level of
greatness and I think it's a tremendous
opportunity for Bill Belichick to write
at the third great chapter I think of
his greatest head coaching career of all
time if he goes out and gets somebody
and I mean I will say this if I can set
aside my emotions the NFC South with
Drew Brees and Matt run any ice there
and and that's gonna be fun and if Cam
Newton just left though right well he's
definitely not coming back I don't think
it's gonna be Teddy Bridgewater fresh
off of New Orleans and I mean Teddy's
got some ability with a new coaching
staff and all that business it is gonna
be pretty dynamite but it's just gonna
be odd bill seeing Brady and pewter you
know on that that's gonna be the first
time you see him in that Buccaneer
journey you know well here's a game that
me and my friends play is like you just
play you play like the the greatest
player in that uniform they retired in
like which broke your heart the most
right like like say like I would say for
the older generation was probably Johnny
Unitas in a Chargers uniform or Joe
Namath in the Rams do you remember Tony
Dorsett in a Buccaneer I mean sorry in a
Broncos Jersey he played one season for
them and Smith went to Arizona Phoenix
yeah Phoenix maybe he's right oh my
body's got a great one Patrick you and
with the Seattle Sonics that
was a tough one just a training hard
pack yes Farben jets and Vikings was
hard and I'm gonna say Brady but the
thing is too is they also passed like
their prime and like Tom Brady like got
a lot of crap last year but it was
really like the receiving corps that we
had like Gronk just demanded double
coverage and kept and that would get
Edelman open so all you had to do now
was once he was gone I think that we
were gambling that he wasn't going to
retire when change his mind when he
didn't we got caught a little
flat-footed and then every team just
doubled Edelman and the other guys
needed to step up like you know there'd
be a blitz and I didn't they wouldn't
cut off their routes the amount of time
I saw Brady thrown to a guys back who
hadn't even turned around so I think he
still has two seasons in him and I'm
gonna route like hell for that guy
because that's the only thing I can do
other than cry on Sundays like I hope he
gets number seven and eight and and then
I hope also Belichick you know fine
obviously finds his next quarterback but
you know I don't know you knew this day
was coming because Brady was 42 Bella
checks close to 70 Bob Kraft is you know
I think I'm feeling like where the
Steelers around 1980 or 81 and all of a
sudden everybody everybody got old you
know yeah which by the way I'm reading a
killer book right now
yeah called their their life's work the
Brotherhood of the 1970s Pittsburgh
Steelers then and now that makes it
great and then also a lot of the great
games they're talking about you can
watch on youtube like last night I
watched the Raiders versus the Steelers
1974 AFC championship game and this is
before the Steelers won their first ring
and the week before the Raiders had
beaten the Dolphins who had just gone
back-to-back and John Madden very rare
mistake evidently said the two best
teams played last week and I guess Chuck
Noll was never a guy big on emotions he
was just an X and O's guy it pissed him
off so much he was in the meeting and
all the players were sitting in here on
those you know student desks with it the
death card is attached to the chair they
were all sitting in those
and he goes John Madden said the best
two teams played last week well I think
he's wrong because the best team in my
opinion is sitting right in this room
and Joe Greene was so excited he stood
up and fist pumped and took the whole
desk with him and the second I read that
I was like I gotta see if this game is
online and I put it on and it's it's
incredible it's the Raiders they're two
years away from that seventy sixteen
that actually beat the pittsburgh
steelers and if you talk to anybody in
pittsburgh that knows that football like
joe bartnik was telling me that was the
best Steeler team it's just Rocky Bleier
and Franco Harris both got hurt late in
the season and it was just like out of
dumb luck but they actually you know if
those guys were both healthy
according to Pittsburgh fans they would
have three peated which has never been
done they would have repeated easily you
said yeah Pittsburgh in that game bill
scored 21 in the fourth quarter to win
Franco Harrison Rocky Bleier combined
for over 200 yards rushing in that game
yeah and and they had been shutting down
that Raiders defense had really been
shutting down the run so it's a big
surprise that they ran all those yeah
they shut down
Duncan Jim kick probably others probably
who was playing for Miami the week
before of it I love that stuff man I
feel I you know I have a whole football
card collection just all the 70s from
1970 right through 79 I got all the oh
and you know this else is great its Curt
Gowdy and dandy Don Meredith up through
the the play-by-play in the color I mean
you just look at how much the game has
changed like first of all the games it's
like in the afternoon it's like 1:00 in
the afternoon right right and it just
starts when it comes to broadcast like
they're lining up for the kickoff and
they just kick it off no pomp no
circumstance when they cut to the crowd
that's the best this you know you can't
find one jersey nobody's wearing a
jersey everybody's wearing street
clothes half the people look like they
could be in that Ron Burgundy anchorman
movie the way people dress smoking in
the crowd and it's really like so just
like just sports fans and Curt Gowdy
brings something up that I started to
watch I went down
rabbit hole is called 19th NFL 74 the
championship chase what is that what is
that oh that's the highlight of the
whole 1974 season and there was a very
there's a there's a great Patriot that
was forgot in history undersized kid
named Mac heron he's known as mini Mac
he was five five-and-a-half yeah you had
to go to the CFL the Patriots signed him
he set a record for all-purpose yardage
that stood for 30 years front on kickoff
punt receiving and running yardage he
disappear in the John Hannah used to
laugh that he would disappear into the
pile and they couldn't find him and he
would shoot out and but the problem is
he partied a little too much it messed
up his career and this is why he left
the Patriots he ended up having a big
party at his house and half the Patriots
were there so Chuck Fairbanks shipped
him out because a lot of people don't
remember that year the Patriots I think
it was 74 that year the Patriots in a
three-week period beat the two-time
defending Super Bowl champion Miami
Dolphins then they beat the Raiders and
then they beat the Steelers three weeks
in a row but then we lost of Bert Jones
in the Coulter Jones the page first yes
for the Patriots and the Colts were sort
of this up-and-coming thing but
everybody knew it was Dolphins Raiders
or Steelers and but anyways Mac Heron
people should I'm surprised I couldn't
remember that but Mac Heron should have
been brought up when Isiah Thomas with
the Celtics had that two-year Roger
where he was this undersized guy that
the whole city fell in love with that
was sort of the second coming of Mac
Baren
Mac Herron I guess it was you could say
as Danny Woodhead before Danny Woodhead
was even born I guess back in the day
this is great causation yeah with Bill
Burt we were talking before to Bill Kris
Brockman and I about you know some of
the old classic games that were we're
beginning to see a little bit more on on
cable and broadcast television about how
you know you're watching those games
there's no yellow line and let you know
where the first down is there's no
there's no blue
you know where the line of scrimmage is
there's no score box you don't know what
time how much time is left on the clock
and and we're so totally coddled as
viewers of TV now you know oh and also
just like how much the NFL was just
catering to football fans back there and
now they do like it's like they're just
commercial fishing just throwing out
like let's have Shakira and JLo like
some of the Super Bowls like from the
seven fun YouTube and you watch them and
the halftime show is like a local
college band yeah and also like the game
was played at like Tulane University so
many times and the game was just on in
the afternoon not anymore it wasn't that
super Super Bowl Sunday and all of that
stuff none of that existed and the NHL
what I can't believe is how how much
slower the game was and how much smaller
the players were to the point they
almost need to make the rinks bigger if
you look at all the open ice in the 80s
the heyday was the perfect combination
the 88 the 80s with the perfect
combination of the enforcers and finesse
players you had some of the greatest in
Fort Wayne Gretzky of enforces Bob
Probert and you literally have been
Gretzky and Mario Lemieux and all eyes
are men and all of these guys and
putting up like 60 70 80 90 goals was
incredible then what killed it was
Patrick walk a min and showed him the
butterfly and then that was it and then
it got big and the pads got big through
Paul Coffey scored like 50 goals as a
defenseman one year I mean it's just
unheard of bill bird quarantine is one
of the greatest sports historians I've
ever met I mean let's be very honest
this is what a bill burr
shelter-in-place it's been it's one of
the greatest sports history
conversations I think I've ever had only
tops I can only talk 70s and 80s because
in 92 I started stand-up and I missed
like this chunk it's almost like like
with music no matter how much I try and
listen to new music
I'm always going to end up going back to
ac/dc and Aerosmith and stuff from my
childhood like I know there's a
different feeling when you list that and
I feel the same thing like I think when
I was a kid like I still had the hope
that I was going to make it to
professional sports and then by the 90s
I knew the dream was over so and I was
watching kids at that point who I was
older then who made it happen and I
didn't so so let me ask you bill before
I let you go you mentioned Jeter before
and when you were referencing Brady
about out took you so long to stop
looking for Jeter when Yankee games were
on after Jeter left you know Jeter is
technically Tom Brady's landlord now did
you see that mansion that Brady
apparently moved into Jeter's mansion in
tampa st. pete did you see that story
you missed oh no I did not but but I was
joking on my podcast that Tom Brady did
what every old white guy does in
Massachusetts after a while you get sick
of the winters so you moved to Florida
you know and then you also don't have to
pay state tax and also there's some rule
there in there where every state has
like some sort of real estate rule that
if you get sued like the first so many
dollars of your ha
can't touch some states it's 500,000
some states it's a million Florida is
unlimited so nobody can touch your real
estate so everyone from Tom Brady to OJ
Simpson
takes advantage of that well Brady's
moving Brady's moving into Derek Jeter's
30,000 875 square foot spot if you will
in South Tampa so Jeter I think is love
is Brady's landlord I wonder how about
any other relationships gonna be you
know I thought you're gonna say that was
Jeter's guesthouse well could be his
on-deck circle
yeah here's the thing he's married to a
supermodel Tom Brady is and I think she
might like the weather in Florida but
like she's not going to be able to
handle that Tampa is okay Miami is where
like all the sexy people go to visit and
buy a house or whatever but like Tampa
is that's real Florida you don't I mean
what do you mean actually not a lot too
soon
that's like you know trucks with the
silver balls hanging off like my truck
had balls
beautiful shooting each other because
they were arguing about how long that
alligator was last night that was 80
feet further next thing you know they
shoot each other that you know mess I
mean that's real you know that redheaded
guy with the busted teeth that started
Scientology that's right in there that's
that's Florida Brady's going to play man
that's where he's going and I needed
that laughs you're the man what don't
worry about it what time are you on
tomorrow do you know exactly what time
you in tomorrow you know I don't know
how it works it starts at 7:00 Eastern
and starts it and then four o'clock
Pacific that's all I know
so it's 4:00 4:00 at 4:00 p.m. out here
West Coast time we're gonna try to make
you laugh and dude I got just as much
out of making you laugh believe me do it
I'm Joan this is the longest I've ever
gone without doing stand-up or anything
I'm just going in the garage and playing
drums like an hour a day I feel like I
still live at home with my parents like
30 years ago I'm waiting for this I'm
wait I'm waiting for the seller lights
to flick on and off to let me know that
it's time for dinner and you try on your
material out on your kid is it you're
just using your good stuff in the house
what are you doing
just workshopping it I'm not chasing it
a long time ago the way the way to get
in the zone
with whatever that you do is you can't
care and you can't think about it you
just have to go up there and just do it
or just kind of let it happen so if I
lose some jokes and I forget them so be
it I don't care I mean it was kidding
who gives us you know that's about my
ask the big thing is everybody's got to
get healthy so we can all get back out
there again and then go you know enjoy
some dance sport that's right
I appreciate American Ninja Warrior for
god sakes I mean what are we doing here
it's like that show does more
backstories than the friggin Olympics I
know American Ninja Warrior is the Law &
Order of sports television it's on all
the time it's okay
and the back stories these people you
learn about them and within two seconds
they're wet in the pool and they're done
and they're like why did you why why'd
you introduce me to somebody that lasts
five seconds I don't understand it but
that's the whole thing it it's my kids
can't get enough of it we can't get
enough of it it's amazing well what is
great what is great though is the thing
that propels that show yeah it's not the
people as much as they try to make it
it's the obstacle course that's that's
them moving the story along so each year
that obstacle course has to get harder
and harder and I hadn't watched it in
like a year and this stuff that they
have these people do it I mean if you
get through that whole course you're
like you would get like a fist bump from
spider-man to a log rolling down to a
hill they got like then they had that
the spider-man jump yeah and then they
got like just a degree of difficulty the
stuff that you have to hang on to I mean
it's like some of the stuff that was the
end of the obstacle course is now in the
middle it's like I remember this was the
hard thing nobody could get past this is
just like you know and we're in the
second quarter and he's upside down what
about you ever seen when they they go
down that hill and they're hanging on to
basically it's like a box it's good
thanks for the call bill let's stay in
touch
let's get you out more let's let's all
stay inside and watch bill and the rest
of his comedy friends tomorrow to pass
the time and raise some money and and
and I appreciate the call bill you take
care of yourself right back at your man
that said comedy gives back calm to
learn more